[Music]
[Music]
we are about to tell you a story that
you might think you know
but unless you know that the ku klux
klan was involved
you're going to want to stick around
because the interface of humanity and
the natural world
is always a very fraught place
pets are a matter of personal preference
but they're also a bit about the
branding like we all know that there's
kind of a feel to a dog person and a cat
person but also
take brine shrimps
that's not a name that suggests a
particularly exciting pet but that did
not stop me when i was seven years old
my dad helped me follow the instructions
on an ad in i think a teenage mutant
ninja turtles comic so that i could
order my very own brine shrimp
of course they were not called brine
shrimp they were called sea monkeys and
they were i'll be honest pretty
difficult to take care of i don't think
they lasted very long
now not everyone had sea monkeys just
like not everyone watched the 1992
sitcom the amazing live sea monkeys
about three human-sized sea monkeys and
the professor played by howie mandel who
enlarged them in fact given that the
show lasted only 11 episodes i don't
know that anyone watched it but that's
okay because we do not need a professor
to enlarge our sea monkeys we have a
microscope
but before we get to the organism behind
all of this magic let's talk a little
bit about the magic itself the
experience of instant life as it was
marketed packaged into a toy the premise
is kind of immense like you feel as if
you are creating life but the
instructions were simple all you needed
according to the original 1972 patent
were three packets packet one contained
the water conditioner packet 2 contained
the eggs and packet 3 contained the food
just add packet 1 to get the water ready
wait 24 hours then add packet 2 and
voila watch in amazement as they
instantly
hatch now the instant life of the sea
monkey is actually the achievement less
of you or the people at sea monkey hq
and more of artemia selena the brine
shrimp
while not technically a shrimp the brine
shrimp is a crustacean found in salty
lakes and ponds and while they're
rebranding as sea monkeys is a more
recent innovation artemia have been
around for over a hundred million years
artemia swim upside down and breathe
through their gills near the base of
their limbs and they spend their days
seeking out their favorite food algae
but artemia also make for great food
themselves which is why they are
cultivated to feed fish being farmed for
your own future meals or aquariums
the artemia's downfall if you want to
call it that is its own resilience
female artemia can produce two types of
eggs the first when the world around it
is comfortable will be thin shelled and
quick to hatch the second though when
the world around it is less comfortable
will be hard shelled a cyst and inside
that cyst is a larva fully developed but
kept in weight until the conditions are
okay for it to leave the cyst
with just the right mixture of salty
water the artemia will emerge from its
rest scientists of course have done the
obvious thing and sent these cysts into
space launching them aboard the apollo
16 and apollo 17 moon missions to assess
their hardiness against cosmic radiation
and many of the eggs were able to hatch
after that exposure though with some
deformities but back here on earth the
hardiness of those cysts makes them well
suited for the more mundane concerns of
fish food in the 1930s a species called
artemia noplei became the live fish food
of choice for many and artemia eggs
continue to be sold for fish cultivation
that's actually how we got ours james
our master of microscopes ordered a
packet of about a million eggs on the
internet and then concocted his own
special briny mixture like a mixologist
at a microscopic bar to give them the
right conditions to emerge in
and artemia could have remained largely
just a matter of fish food except that
in 1957 a man named harold von braunhutt
entered a pet store and left with an
idea his muse
was a bucket full of fish food you know
artemia
this was a time when ant farms were
popular and von braun hut was struck
with the notion that maybe what ant
farms needed was an aquatic twist but
there was a challenge hatching artemia
as fish food is not quite the same as
hatching artemia as a pet you only need
the fish food to last as long as it
takes the fish to eat it but the artemia
that von braun hood wanted to sell as a
pet only lasted a few days so as one
would do he recruited the help of a
marine biologist a guy named anthony de
agostino to create a heartier artemia
though the secrets of how they did this
we have not been able to uncover but the
science alone is not enough to sell
shrimp and von braunhoot was dealing
with a customer base that already had
its heart broken by a similar product
called the instant fish which used
dormant african killer fish eggs but was
unable to meet the demands of its buyers
the thing to know about harold von
braunhood though was that his main
occupation was
showman he'd successfully sold a product
called invisible goldfish which came
with a fishbowl and fish food but no
fish
so if you are a man who can sell no fish
then you are definitely a man who can
sell sea monkeys and von braunhoot was
able to do that by turning to comic book
advertisements and there the kingdom of
sea monkeys was built
but the showmanship wasn't just in the
advertising every time a kid added the
second packet in their instant life kit
they were getting a bit of the same
flair that made von braun hut's other
creations so thrilling because packet
one you know the the ozone that was
supposed to condition your water and
make it nice and homey for that second
packet of eggs that you'd add 24 hours
later yeah that packet wasn't just water
conditioner it also had some eggs and
packet 2 the one with the eggs didn't
just have eggs it also had some
water-soluble dye in it and by the time
you added that packet the first round of
eggs would already have been hatched but
they would be difficult to see until the
water filled with dye and made their
hatched bodies visible and the result as
the patent says is the impression of
instant life we should warn you now that
the history of the sea monkey only gets
darker from here
harold von braunhoot was a white
supremacist who when he had to go see
the us attorney after lending a member
of the ku klux klan money to buy illegal
guns did bring some sea monkeys with him
and because of this association comic
book companies stopped advertising his
creations but von braunhoot was still
able to sell his sea monkeys in other
ways
after his death in 2007 von braun
braunhoot's widow signed a deal with a
toy company to sell sea monkeys only to
later sue them for breach of contract
and trade infringement the toy company
claimed they were actually sourcing
different artemia now and while the case
was settled we do not know what the
terms were of this sea monkey settlement
[Music]
harold von braunhood created a story
around artemia that created an entirely
different creature to turn their most
remarkable accomplishment into a sleight
of hand and the showmanship was
certainly clever allowing us to imagine
that there are tiny individuals living
tiny lives in tiny worlds like ours but
of course that is not the life of the
brine shrimp nor does it need to be the
sea monkey's less contrived story is out
there not frozen in time but simply
unfolding in millions of different
directions over tens of millions of
years artemia you were once a sea monkey
to me but now i know the truth
you are you
which is a much better thing to know
[Music]
thank you for coming on this
extra surprising journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us don't forget you've only got one day
to pre-order that tardigrade t-shirt in
the color of your choice before one of
them goes away forever so visit
dftba.com or click the link in the
description if you'd like to order one
of those
hey the people on our screen right now
they are our patreon patrons the ones
that allow us to look at the micro
cosmos and say
what stories could this tell about our
world and how surprised are we going to
be when we start uncovering those
details
we could not do that work without these
people so if you like what we do they
are the people to thank and i also like
what we do so i would like to say thank
you to them if you want to see more from
our master of microscopes james weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us i bet you there's a subscribe
button somewhere nearby